nachher be man vieles vielleicht um d
stehen we das alles machen können das
das das aber muss er lernen erstm ich
glaube an Gott der existiert und der
wird mir
helfen man muss do klar denken können
man muss ich überlegen was wirklich
wichtig
ist drei Gesichter drei Geschichten
stellvertretend für
Tausende in Deutschland steigt die Zahl
der Menschen ohne Wohnung zum Stichtag
im Sommer 2022 waren knapp eine halbe
Million Menschen wohnungslos allein im
wohlhabenden München sind es mehr als 10
000 einer von ihnen ist
Peter verloren oder die Arbeit Halt
verloren das ist nur mal so weil war von
gefahren so in seinem früheren Leben hat
Peter als Fliesenleger
gearbeitet seit Jahren lebt auf der
Straße wenn damit noch von vne anfangen
würde wenn ich die Möglichkeit hätte
dann würde ich nie wieder auf der Straße
leben solange ich keine Arbeit komme ich
auch keine Wohnung aber da ist 60 Jahre
alt bin oder jung bin sowieso keine
Arbeit mehr also einüber ich bleib auf
der
stße peter hat seit Jahren kein
Personalausweis mehr in den ätern
existiert er nicht troffene die länger
obdachlos sind fühlen sich oft nicht
mehr wahrgenommen macht Peter das wütend
wütend Weise ungern oder Sel enttäuscht
ja weil wenn ich wütend werde dann gehe
lieber schwutzen damit Du wiederuhig wer
das traffoh Häuschen an der ISA ist seit
eineinhalb Jahren sein Zuhause seine
Wünsche für die Zukunft sind bescheiden
B Schuh und guten Schlafs kanst gar
nichts alles was hilft gegen die Kälte
die hohe Inflation und steigende Mieten
lassen immer mehr Menschen in die Armut
rutschen die Leiterin der Münchner
Bahnhofsmission sieht täglich wie der
Druck auf Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen wächst wir hatten vor Corona
im Jahr 90.000 Kontakte in etwa und wir
werden heuer ungefähr bei 240.000
Kontakten sein die Zahlen haben sichtbar
spürbar zugenommen und sind wahnsinnig
viele Menschen die zu uns kommen die
Pandemie hat vieles verschärft zudem
spielen persönliche Schicksalsschläge
eine Rolle Scheidungen Arbeitslosigkeit
Depressionen auch viele geflüchtete und
Menschen aus dem Osten der EU sind
wohnungslos und schlagen sich in der
Statistik
nieder also die Gruppe ist sehr
heterogen sind ganz unterschiedliche
Menschen also was wir schon merken dass
die Menschen viel verwahrlos das sind
zum Teil auch
ja auch depressiver auch irgendwo sich
selber mehr aufgegeben haben früher
kamen die Menschen auch Ende des Monats
weil es halt immer gereicht hat mit dem
Geld und jetzt kommen sie halt schon
Anfang des Monats Mitte des Monats viele
Menschen auf der Straße brauchen
medizinische Versorgung und erhalten Sie
dank des Engagements von Freiwilligen
Marianne Sticks Fachärztin für
Allgemeinmedizin ist seit Jahren
ehrenamtlich bei ärzte der Welt es sind
insgesamt Menschen die keinerlei Zugang
oder kaum einen Zugang zu dem
öffentlichen Gesundheitsversorgung haben
der Blutdruck ist schlecht
eingestellt die Pumpfunktion vom Herzen
ist oft schlecht dadurch kommt zu
Stauungen in den Beinen was die
wohsituation noch weiter verschlechtert
es ist ein Rattenschwanz an an
verschiedenen Dingen die da
zusammenkommen
ja Menschen auf der Straße verschleppen
auf ihre Krankheiten weil sie kaum
Möglichkeiten haben zum Arzt zu gehen
diese Patient ist fast blind die Folge
einer nicht behehandelten Diabetes doch
häufig leidet auch die seelische
Gesundheit ihres letzten
langzeitzuckers haben eine Psychologin
die zu unserem zu unserem Team gehört
ich würde schon meinen dass dass es
sieen gut hätte wenn sie D mal
vorbeikommen dann wird die Last
vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner ja trägt
auch dazu bei dass der Blutdruck besser
wird ich fühle mich nicht alleine
ich bin so froh dass solche Stellen gibt
wie hier ob
Medikamente und die Ärzte Gott sei Dank
die ger
Berat finde ich ganz toll wenn man lebt
ohne medizinische Versorgung und man ist
krank dann das ist das ist ein Gefühl
der
Hilflosigkeit Maria lebt seit einigen
Wochen im frauenobdach in München
weil der Vermieter ihr wegen Eigenbedarf
kündigte hat Maria ihre Wohnung verloren
deswegen ist sie jetzt im frauenopdach
weil sie kaum etwas sieht ist es
schwierig eine passende Wohnung zu
finden ich wünsche dass es mit sehen
bisschen besser wird wenigstens ein Auge
dass ich bisschen sehen kann trotz
vieler Rückschläge hat Maria den festen
Glauben dass sich bald alles zum Guten
wendet die Hoffnung habe ich nicht
verloren wie B es dass S so
hoffnungsvoll bleibt
ich habe Energie also da ich glaube an
Gott der existiert und der wird mir
helfen danke schön
bitte viele der 100ta000 Wohnungslosen
in Deutschland haben ein Dach über dem
Kopf weil sie in Sammelunterkünften
übernachten können manche meiden diese
Stellen aus Angst vor Gewalt Krankheiten
oder weil sie fürchten dort bestohlen zu
werden wie viele Obdachlose es gibt ist
nicht bekannt und auch auf der Straße
gibt es keine Sicherheit es ist ein
täglicher
Überlebenskampf Bernhard wurde auf der
Straße zu einem
Überlebenskünstler man schläft nicht
nachts im Park ja das macht man nicht
nachts im Park schlafen wo praktisch
kein Mensch unterwegs ist ja wenn du da
was auf die wütze kriegst dann merkt das
praktisch niemand ich schlaf bewusst
immer an belelebt Ordnung ich rede im
Schlaf okay dann kriegt halt jemand mit
wenn ich irgendw Stuss im Schlaf Rede
aber ich lebe noch ja das ist ja
unterschiedlich meine man muss sich im
mal auf das wesenliche konzentrieren ne
Bernhard ist seit vier Jahren
obdachlos manchmal sind es ganz
alltägliche Dinge die für Obdachlose zum
Problem werden man sollte es jeden Tag
viel trockensbrot
essen manche essen auch Chips oder
Salzstangen hat alles den gleichen
Effekt es stopft man hat Schwierigkeiten
geschealte Toilette zu
finden wenn man viel trockenes Brot ist
dann kann man es lange aufhalten ein
Kollege hat mir auch den den Tipp
gegeben steckt eine alte Zeitung in die
Hose ja ja halt mal bis nachmag dein
stuhlgum auf auch wenn du viel Brot
gegessen hast trockenes Brot schaff das
mal ist sicherlich ein ekliges aber die
Wahrheit die Realität es gibt Konkurrenz
um Toiletten Schlafplätze Essen es gibt
keine Freundschaften die gibt ich
versuche es immer
wieder klappt aber meistens
nicht auf der Straße ist man nie allein
und trotzdem einsam drei Geschichten
zwischen Resignation und
Hoffnung